This is an FOM
lecture on the
introduction
to the head and
neck given by
Dr. Aki Watanabe.
My job today is to
convince you that the
head and the neck that
supports it is a truly
special region. And
why is that? Well, if
you look across different
animals, so here
we have a dinosaur,
human, and a gorilla.
And when you
pay attention
to the post
cranial skeleton,
you can see that a lot
of the appendicular
and the axial
skeletons remain pretty
similar across the
different species. But when
you pay attention
to the head, this is
where you see remarkable
variation in form.
Perhaps more relevant
to what you're doing,
which is going
through med school and
becoming physicians,
is that the head is in
a primary way that you
establish communication
and a connection
with your patients.
So head and the
neck that supports
it is indeed a
special region.
so in today's lecture
it will be divided into
three parts so the
first part will cover
the head and neck
architecture or the lay of
the land of the head
and neck and then in
the second part we'll
cover the special senses
and organs that exist
only in the head
and the neck and then
we'll end this lecture
by covering the cranial
nerves and giving an
introductory overview
of these wonderfully
complex and multifunctional
set of nerves.
So before we move on
to the lecture content,
I wanted to go over
some of the basic
guidelines that my
lectures will follow.
So any red text on
slides means that
you need to know for
the exams. Similarly,
anatomical structures
that are labeled
in different figures
in red or in red
highlights are also
fair game for the exams.
and then make sure
to pay attention to
the clinical
correlates. These are
what you would call
high yield topics.
And then lastly, as
a general advice,
go over the
learning objectives
listed in the
course preparation
guide for these lectures.
So let's start with a
little review. So the
neck serves as a
conduit between the head
and basically the rest
of the body that we've
already covered. So
these include the
thorax, upper limb,
and the back. So it has
various structures that
go in and out, a lot
of them that you've
already covered. So here
you can pause the
video and think about
the different vessels,
nerves, and other
structures that go
through the head and neck.
Hopefully you were
able to identify some
of these important
structures. So let's start
with the nerves. So
we have the vagus
nerve and the brachial
plexus, which you
learned previously. And
then you also have the
vessels that you're
also fairly familiar
with at this point.
So you have the common
carotid artery and
internal jugular vein.
And then you
also have other
structures like the
cervical vertebrae
and esophagus
and the trachea.
So let's talk about
the skeletal system
in the head and
neck. So we have
the skull, which
is pretty obvious
structure, but please
keep in mind that
skull includes both
the cranium and
the mandible, which
forms a lower jaw.
And you also have
the hyoid, which
is a U-shaped
bone. It's a unique
structure where it's
a bone that doesn't
articulate or
connect with another
bone, and it aids
in swallowing.
You also have the
laryngeal cartilages,
which is a set of
cartilaginous tissues
that support the
voice box, which is
allowing me to talk
for this lecture.
focusing on the upper
part of the cervical
vertebral series you
have the atlas which
supports the skull
and the axis which
is the second cervical
vertebra or c2 and
so just to go over
some of the specific
structures on the
atlas or c1 there's the
superior articular
surface which is going
to connect with the
occipital condyles on
the underside of the
skull and the The
atlas will allow for
up and down motion. So
if you want to say yes
non-verbally to your
friends, then you
can thank the atlas.
And an axis has this
structure called a
dens, which means a
tooth. And this forms
a pivot that allows
the atlas to rotate.
So axis allows your
head to move in
sideways orientation.
So when you
want to say no to
things non-verbally,
you will be using
the axis. Yes.
Continuing on with the
skull. So the skull
looks like it's one
unit and functionally it
does serve as one unit,
but it's important
to know that it's
composed of 22 bones that
are fused together and
a couple or few middle
ear ossicles. So
ossicles mean tiny bones
and they sit in the
middle ear and they help
amplify the noise so
you can hear better.
And the skull is
split into two
different regions
or groupings. So
you have the
neurocranium, which
another word for it
is the brain case. And
as the name implies,
it houses the brain
and protects the
brain. And then you
have the visceral
cranium, which are
the bones that make
up the face and so
here are some of
the bones that you
need to know so you
have the frontal
which forms the kind of
the forehead parietal
bone temporal bone
zygomatic bone maxilla
and then you have
the mandible and
you can also try to
separate them and
this is called
exploded figure where
you can see sort
of the shape of
individual bones that
make up the skull.
So, so far, we've
just covered the adult
skull and the skeletal
system, but it's
important to know
that bones are living
tissue and that they
change throughout
development. So most
notably, in infants,
newborns, you have a
soft spot on the skull
called fontanelles. And
so these are fibrous,
soft tissues between
the cranial bones.
And so these sit in
between some of the
bones that we just
talked about. And these
fontanelles allow
movement among the
skull bones. And why
do you think that is?
Well, it has two
functions. So the first
function is that when
the baby is being born
and going through the
birth canal, it allows
the skull bones to
move around and even
go on top of each
other a little bit so
that the baby can be
born and the head can
fit through and go
through the birth canal.
The another reason
is these pontinelles
stay a little bit
longer after birth
to allow for the
growth of the brain.
And so there are
different types of
fontanelles. So here we
have labeled anterior
fontanelle, which sits
between the frontal
and parietal bones.
And this is the largest
fontanelle. And you
also have the lateral
fontanelles towards
the side of the
skull. And then you
also have the posterior
fontanelle between the
parietal and occipital
bones. So both the
lateral and the
posterior fontanelles,
they close up within
kind of few months of
the baby being born.
But then the anterior
fontanelle is going
to exist and remain
up until, you know,
year to year and a
half after birth.
So, you know, if
you're handling or, you
know, if you know a
baby and if you notice
a soft spot, as long
as it's, you know,
still there and the
baby is no older
than a year and a
half, there's nothing
to worry about. So
you can explain to the
parents that this is
totally normal. And
it's actually a good
thing that the baby
has these fontanelles
with soft spots.
And so I just alluded
to the fact that bone
is living tissue. And
then it's important
to know that there's
dynamism to the
scalpel system. So this
is no different with
the skull and
the mandible. So,
or sorry, the skull,
including the cranium
and the mandible.
and so on the left we
have an infant all the
way to a gerontic or
more senior individual
on the right and so
you have probably a
skull from a adolescent
individual and then
of course adult human
skull second from the
right so what you're
seeing here is that
the skull changes in
how it looks throughout
somebody's lifetime
so in the beginning
you tend to have these
rounded large orbits
or the eye socket
you also see this
anterior fontanelle here
and you obviously
start with no teeth and
then as you grow you
obviously gain more
teeth and the skull
becomes taller and then
after you know later
in adulthood or in in
more senior individuals,
the skull again
becomes more rounded
or globular, and you
also lose teeth. So
it's kind of poetic in
a sense that the older
individual tends to
start resembling an
infant later in life.
All right, now let's
move on from the
skeletal system and
talk about the nervous
system. So the
first thing I will
say is that the
brain anatomy will be
covered in detail
next semester in
neuroanatomy. So there's
not actually a lot
you need to know for
the nervous system.
One thing that I would
like to point out
is that the menisual
layers that you
learned previously,
so these are the dura
arachnoid and the pia
mater that you learned
that surrounds the
spine, spinal cord,
continues on into
the brain. And so you
still have the same
spaces. For example,
the subarachnoid
space contains a
cerebral spinal fluid.
And that's the same
thing that's happening
around the brain as
well. These are
continuous structures.
And in the brain, you
have other structures,
for example, the
choroid plexus that
generates and
produces the cerebral
spinal fluid. And then
you have these ventricles
and there's a set
of four of them
that are cavities where
the cerebral spinal
fluid flows through
within the brain.
Now let's move on
to talking about
ingestion and
respiration and structure
that are related
to these functions.
So in the head,
you have the GI
and respiratory
systems that are
connected through
the pharynx.
And first, you
have the nasal
cavity inside of
your nose, and
you also have
the oral cavity.
And these are separated
by the hard palate
and the soft palate,
so the fleshy
extension of the heart
palate posteriorly.
So what I want
you to do is
breathe in deeply
through your nose
and let's follow
the pathway of the
air. So the air,
when you do that, is
going to go through
the external
nonaris and then enter
the nasal cavity.
And then when
it passes the
internal nares,
then it has entered
a part called
nasopharynx.
And nasopharynx
ends at the uvula,
at the tip of
the soft palate.
And then beyond that
is the oropharynx,
which is posterior
to the oral cavity.
And then past the
epiglottis, this little
cover for the larynx
and the trachea, so
the food doesn't get
going through there,
that's a region called
a laryngopharynx.
So that's where it
starts up until the
esophagus or the
larynx. So the pharynx
is divided into three
parts, and these
are the boundaries
of those three parts.
So what we're going
to do is we talked
about how the air
moves from the
nasal cavity into
the trachea, but
let's just review
that pathway once
again. So breathe
through your nose.
And what's happening
with the air is it's
going to go through the
nasal cavity, and then
enter the nasopharynx,
the first part of
the pharynx, and then
go to the oropharynx
and laryngopharynx.
And then it's going to
air is going to mostly
go into the trachea,
right through the larynx
and into the lungs.
And the reverse path of
that is when
you exhale air.
On the other hand,
when you have food, you
will go through hopefully
the oral cavity.
I hope you don't
ingest food through
the nasal cavity. So
go through the oral
cavity and when it
passes the uvula, you've
entered the oral
pharynx and then
laryngopharynx. And of
course, you don't want
food going into your
larynx and trachea.
So it's going to
bypass past that and go
into the esophagus
and into the stomach.
So now we're going
to talk about
the mechanics
of ingestion,
which is a very
elegant system.
So first, what
happens is when you're
processing the food,
you've ingested
it and it's in
the oral cavity.
The first phase of
ingestion is called
the oral phase. And
this is where the
depression or sorry,
the elevation of the
tongue is going to
push the bolus of the
food posteriorly
towards the pharynx.
And then the next
section or phase two
is called the pharyngeal
phase. And this
is where the soft
palate and the uvula
elevates to close up
the pathway between
the oropharynx and
the nasopharynx.
And so what this
does is it prevents
the food from entering
the nasal cavity.
And the third stage is
called the esophageal
phase. And this
is where the food
that's already in
the oropharynx gets
pushed down through
sequential contraction
of pharyngeal
constrictor muscles, and
then keeps on going
through palestalsis
through the esophagus
into the stomach.
And so the important
step here, well, all
three are important,
but something to know
about the second phase
or the pharyngeal
phase is that the soft
palate and the uvula
closes that pathway
into the nasal
cavity. So what I want
you to do is, oh, and
the other thing that
happens, excuse me,
is that the epiglottis
is going to come down
to block that pathway
between the oral,
sorry, the laryngopharynx
into the larynx.
So the food doesn't get
through there. So the
important consequence
of these things
happening in phase two
is that you can't breathe
and swallow at the same
time. So what I want
you to do now is try
to swallow either the
food that you might
have in front of you or
your spit works as
well, and try to breathe
at the same time. And
hopefully you find that
you can't do those
things simultaneously.
But an infant has a
superpower because
what they have
to do is suckle
and drink a lot
of milk and this
could take tens of
seconds to minutes
and during that
time obviously the
baby needs to breathe.
So how do babies
do that? Well what
happens in babies
is that the larynx
and the epiglottis
sit more superiorly
than in adults.
And what happens when
a baby's suckling is
that these two
structures, or excuse me,
the epiglottis and
the soft palate or the
uvula as well, interlock
in the middle of
the oral cavity. And
what this allows is
that it prevents the
milk from going into
the nasal cavity, but
rather the fluid or
the milk is going to
pass laterally and
bypass the pathway
into the larynx and the
trachea. So it goes
around that hole and
then flows posteriorly
into the esophagus.
So it's an elegant
kind of solution
to allowing
babies to breathe
and suckle at
the same time.
Okay, and let's also talk
about paranasal sinuses.
And so there are four
sets of paranasal
sinuses. They're paired,
which means they're
on both sides of
the head. And all
these paranasal sinuses
are named after the
bones that they sit
in. So for example,
the frontal sinus,
which is located sort
of in the middle,
just above your eyes,
that sits inside of
the frontal bone,
and ethmoid sinus
sits in the ethmoid
bone, sphenoid
sinus, that sits more
posteriorly, sits
inside of the sphenoid
bone, and maxidur
sinus, which is
going to be inside
the maxilla bone.
and all these sinuses
are connected to
the nasal cavity via
an opening the fram
not called osteo
and so the there are
multiple roles for
peranasal sinuses so
first not so much
the case in humans or
that it doesn't really
matter but they it
lightens the skull
weight a little bit
and it also allows for
the inhaled air to be
more humidified and
heated and then also
increases the resonance
for hearing. And this
is a reason why your
voice sounds differently
when you're talking
and hearing versus
when you're hearing a
recording of yourself.
And the clinical
relevance of paranasal
sinuses, and you
would have experienced
this if you'd gotten
a common cold, for
example, is that these
small openings that
connect these paranasal
sinuses to the
nasal cavity often
gets clogged up, either
through inflammation
or swelling of the
nasal lining and from
a virus. So what this
does is it prevents
the sinuses to be
drained. So the sinuses
increase in pressure,
and that tends to
lead to discomfort
or facial pain. And
that's what you're
feeling often when
you get a common cold.
Now, let's talk
about the vascular
system, and we'll start
with the arteries.
So, in the neck,
we start off with a
common carotid,
which comes from the
brachiocephalic trunk
on the right side of
the body and the
aortic arch on the left
side of the body,
and that splits,
while it's passing
through the neck, into
external carotid and
internal carotid.
And as their name
implies, the external
carotid supplies
predominantly
structures that are
outside of the skull.
And internal carotid,
on the other hand,
supplies structures
inside of the skull.
And so that
includes the brain.
And a couple important
structures to
take note. And this
happens where the common
carotid artery splits
into the external
internal carotid
arteries. And so
one of those structures
is called the
carotid sinus. And
that's a slightly dilated
portion that's
close to this split.
And there are nerves
coming from the
glossopharyngeal
nerve or cranial nerve
nine around this
carotid sinus, and
that is sensitive
to the stretching.
And this allows the
carotid sinus to be
a structure that's
responsible for
monitoring blood
pressure. So when it's
stimulated, meaning that
when it's stretched,
that means that the
blood pressure is
high. So what it does
is it leads to slowing
of the heart rate
once the stretching
is detected, leading
to vasodilation and
eventually decrease
in blood pressure.
Another important sensory
system that exists
in this part of the
body is the carotid
body, which is a cluster
of cells, specialized
cells that are
sensitive to the level
of oxygen and carbon
dioxide in the blood.
And this is
also innervated
by the
glossopharyngeal nerve.
So in the last parts
of this part of the
lecture on the head
and neck anatomy or the
architecture, we're
going to cover three
important danger zones
of the head and neck.
And so the first one
is called a terion,
a junction of the frontal
bone, the parietal
bone, the temporal
bone, and the bone
and this region is
particularly thin so in
terms of skull thickness
and what's more
important is that there's
an important artery
called the middle
veninial artery which
unfortunately isn't
figured in this
illustration but it sits
right underneath the
skull or the internal
surface of the skull.
So if you are hit with,
for example, a blunt
instrument to the side,
that might fracture
these thin bones, and
it could lead to the
rupturing of this
middle meningeal artery,
and you can have
hemorrhaging inside
the skull. And so
this will lead to
compression of the
brain tissue. And
obviously this can
be life threatening.
So this is a good way
or a good point to
cover different types
of what's called
intracranial hemorrhage
or hematoma. So this
is obviously a very
serious situation
where you have blood
accumulation, internal
bleeding in the
endocranial or the brain
cavity. And so this
leads to obviously loss
of blood supply in
some parts of the
intracranial structures
like the brain, but
also it introduces
compression for the
brain, which is also
very life-threatening.
So the three different
types of intracranial
hematomas that I'd
like you to know
include epidural
hematoma, which occurs
between the skull
and the dura mater.
The second type
is subdural
hematoma. So
this is where the
bleeding or internal
bleeding happens
between the dura mater
and the arachnoid.
And this happens
when there's
a rupture in the
bridging veins
as well as the
sagittal sinus
right here between
the two hemispheres of
the brain. And you
also have subarachnoid
hemorrhage between the
arachnoid mater and the
pia mater. And so this
is very common when
you have a cerebral
arteries rupture and
this is obviously more
internal right here.
Now let's move
on to veins.
And just like arteries
and the carotid arteries,
you have external
jugular and internal
jugular and they work
mostly in similar ways
where external jugular
is gonna drain the
blood from the temporal
and occipital regions
outside of the skull
and internal jugular
vein drains the face,
but also structures that
are inside the skull,
including the brain.
And there's a very
special structure
called the cavernous
sinus inside of the
brain cavity. And so
this sits right next
to the pituitary
fossa or the pituitary
gland and this is a
structure where the
venous sinus covers
or is outside of an
artery and very important
nerves. In other
words, We have the
internal carotid
artery, a branch of it
here, and you have a
set of five cranial
nerves or four if
you just count cranial
nerve five as one
of them. But these
are the two divisions.
You have cranial
nerves that are
bathing in deoxygenated
blood, which is
a very unique
configuration that's
only happening in
the cavernous sinus.
So you have, well,
what's inside
the cavernous
sinus? Let's go over
one by one. So
you have a branch
of the internal
carotid artery.
You also have
cranial nerve
three or ocular
motor nerve,
trochlear nerve,
deucin's nerve, and
these three cranial
nerves, which we will
cover a little bit
later, are responsible
for eye movement.
And then you also
have two divisions of
the fifth cranial
nerve, the trigeminal
nerve. So that includes
ophthalmic division
and the maxillary
divisions of cranial
nerve five that are
also to the side.
So there are important
nerves and arterial
structures that sit
within the cavernous
sinus. Well, what's the
clinical significance
of that? Well, we
have facial vein,
which drains blood
from the face of an
individual, and these
veins are valveless.
So depending on the
internal pressure within
these venous structures,
blood may actually
flow backwards through
the superior and
inferior ophthalmic
veins. So these are the
veins that are located
on the superior part
and inferior part of
the orbit or the eye
socket. And if there's
backflow of blood, these
would directly lead
into the cavernous
sinus, which we just
talked about. So this means
that infections
around the nose, for
example, if you have
pimples or boils around the
nose, this can easily
spread into the
cavernous sinus. And we
just talked about the
important structures
that are located there,
including the pterotary
and the branch of
the internal carotid
and the cranial nerves.
so this triangle
area around the
nose is our
second danger zone
and now we're going to
finish off by talking
about the third and
the last danger zone
but before we do i
need to introduce the
structures that are
relevant so we're
going to go back to
talking about the neck
and in the neck we
have a series of fascia
and so we have investing
fascia which goes
around almost the
perimeter of the neck.
And these fascia
collectively form
different
compartments, just
like in the upper
and lower limbs.
And so again, we went
over the investing
fascia, which are
the most superficial.
And then we have the
pre-tracheal fascia,
which surrounds the
thyroid gland here,
the trachea and the
esophagus. So it forms
a compartment that
includes these structures.
We also have the
carotid sheath, which
surrounds the internal
carotid and the
common carotid and the
external carotid. And
then you also have
the internal jugular.
And they're on the
both sides of the neck.
And you also have
the prevertebral
fascia, which
surrounds the
vertebrae and the
surrounding muscles.
And finally, we
have what's called
the alar fascia,
which connects the
two carotid sheets
on both sides.
So the third and the
last danger zone is
this potential space
between the alar fascia
and the prevertebral
fascia. And the reason
why it's a danger
zone is because if
infection occurs in
this space, then there's
an easy route from near
the head region all
the way down through
the neck, through the
thorax and the
mediastinum, and down all
the way down to the
diaphragm. So it's an
easy sort of highway for
infections to spread.
And so this is danger
space for zone number
three. And this is
the space between the
alar fascia and the
prevertebral fascia.
All right. So now that
we covered the lay
of the land in the
head and the neck,
here's an example question
that will showcase
what an exam question
would look like.
So a 30-year-old
patient is admitted to a
hospital with a
traumatic injury to the
head. CT scan reveals
that the left middle
meningeal artery
between the skull and
the dura mater has
ruptured. So which type
of intracranial
hematoma or hemorrhage
describes this injury?
So we have a cross
-section from a CT
scan, and then we have
this illustration from
one of the previous
slides that show the
different types of
intracranial hemorrhage
slash hematoma.
so i will give
you about 15
seconds to think
of the answer okay
so the important
information here is that
the middle meningeal
artery sits between
the skull and the
dura model and we
learned this is relevant
to the first danger
zone the terion which
is to the side of
the skull this is
this particularly thin
part of the skull and
so because the rupture
happened on the artery
that sits between
the skull and the
dura mater it's going
to be in that epidural
space over here
so the answer is e
epidural hematoma